julián trabaja con un pequeño grupo de
40 empleados cada empleado recibe una
calificación anual la mejor de estas es
excede las expectativas
la gerencia sostienen que el 10 por
ciento de los empleados obtienen esta
calificación
sin embargo julia sospecha que en
realidad esta tasa es menor ella obtuvo
una muestra aleatoria anónima de 10
calificaciones de su equipo de trabajo
desea usar los resultados de la muestra
para probar la hipótesis nula a la cual
establece que la proporción realmente es
del 10% contra la hipótesis alternativa
la cual establece que la proporción real
es menor que el 10% dónde p es la
proporción de todos los empleados de su
equipo que obtuvieron excede las
expectativas cuáles son las condiciones
que cumplen la muestra de julián para
realizar este tipo de prueba cuando nos
preguntan por la
condiciones están hablando de tres
condiciones la condición de aleatoriedad
la condición de normalidad esto ya lo
hemos visto antes y la condición de
independencia pausa el vídeo y trata de
resolver esto por tu cuenta
posteriormente revisaremos cada una de
estas condiciones a fin de verificar si
la muestra de julián cumple con estas
condiciones que le permitan garantizar
los resultados de la prueba de
significancia
bien hagámoslo juntos empecemos por
recordar qué es lo que hacemos en una
prueba de significancia tenemos una
hipótesis nula am y también una
hipótesis alternativa y lo que hacemos
es a partir de una población que en este
caso es de 40 empleados tomamos una
muestra en este caso juliá tomó una
muestra de tamaño 10
posteriormente obtenemos estadísticos de
la muestra en este caso la proporción
muestral a la cual llamaremos p 1
sombrero para entonces calcular un valor
p si continuamos con nuestro repaso un
valor p es la probabilidad de obtener un
resultado como éste o más extremo
suponiendo que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera en este caso en particular y
dado que ella sospecha que ni siquiera
el 10% recibe la calificación excede las
expectativas esta va a ser la
probabilidad de que el estadístico
muestral sea menor o igual
que el que obtuvo de la muestra de
tamaño n igual a 10 dado que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera
y si este valor pm es menor que el nivel
de significancia predeterminado no sé 5%
o 10% lo que se haya determinado con
antelación
entonces se rechazará a la hipótesis
nula pues la probabilidad de obtener
este resultado es bastante pequeña por
lo tanto se sugieren la hipótesis
alternativa por el contrario si el valor
p no es menor que el nivel de
significancia entonces no se va a
rechazar la hipótesis nula la clave kim
y ese es el tema del vídeo es que con el
objetivo de que sea válida la prueba de
significancia se tienen que hacer
ciertas suposiciones en relación al
proceso de muestreo y a la distribución
muestral de los estadísticos las cuáles
son las condiciones que hemos enunciado
por aquí
la primera condición es la condición de
aleatoriedad la cual implica que los
elementos de la muestra fueron
seleccionados aleatoriamente cumplió
julia con la condición de aleatoriedad
pausa el vídeo y responder
bueno aquí mencionan que obtuvo una
muestra aleatoria anónima de 10
calificaciones de su equipo de trabajo
nos dice cómo la obtuvo pero vamos a
suponer que esto es cierto así que en
efecto cumplen con la condición de
aleatoriedad qué sucede con la condición
de normalidad bueno esta condición
establece que el valor esperado de
éxitos que es el tamaño de la muestra
multiplicado por el valor de la
proporción y el valor esperado de
fracasos que es el tamaño de la muestra
x 1 menos este valor de la proporción
tienen que ser ambas por lo menos
iguales a 10 así que tienen que ser
mayores o iguales a 10 ahora bien en
este caso cuáles son estos valores
bueno en es igual a 10 es la cantidad de
calificaciones que ella obtuvo en su
muestra por otra parte el valor de la
proporción recuerda que cuando hacemos
una prueba de significancia vamos a
suponer que l
tesis nula no es verdadera la cual
establece que el valor de la proporción
es 0.1 así que esto es 0.1 y 10.1 es 0.9
y ahora observan 10 por 0.1 bueno eso en
definitiva no es mayor que 10 ya con eso
no se cumple la condición de normalidad
pero inclusive la segunda opción 10 por
0.9 tampoco es mayor o igual a 10 así
que en definitiva no se cumplen esta
condición de normalidad no podemos
sostener que la distribución muestral
que aproximadamente normal lo cual
requerimos para hacer este tipo de
cálculos por último pero no menos
importante tenemos la condición de
independencia es decir se necesita
independencia para garantizar que los
resultados del muestreo sean
independientes entre sí es decir el
hecho de obtener un resultado de éxito o
fracaso es independiente en cada
uno de los resultados previos ahora sí
ella tomó una muestra con reemplazo
entonces si se cumple la condición de
independencia si no lo hizo con
reemplazo tenemos que revisar la regla
del 10% si el tamaño de la muestra es
menor que el 10% del tamaño de la
población podemos considerar que se
cumple la condición de independencia
aunque no haya habido reemplazo pero
observamos en este caso tamaño de la
muestra es del 25 por ciento del tamaño
de la población obviamente es mayor que
el 10% así que tampoco se cumplen la
condición de independencia por lo tanto
si ella fuera a calcular este valor p
para su prueba de significancia yo no
estaría completamente convencido de sus
resultados pues no cumplió dos de estas
tres condiciones y esa es la conclusión
de este problema nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo